[Music]
[Applause]
season 15 of So You Think You Can Dance
your hero audition what are the emotions
you're feeling talk to me grow at all
I'm honestly feeling so excited to just
be myself and finally after all these
years show the judges why I deserve to
be on season 15 what is the reason what
makes you special and unique well I
think what makes me special is you know
I'm not only versatile in my dance
styles but I'm also versatile with my
gender so I like to play with female and
male characters I identify as a male but
today I'm here as my drag character miss
estranja one of RuPaul's legendary
children and I just can't wait to let
the judges have it you know you've got
the glitter you've got the works what is
your routine what is your dance
background and experience sure so I
started dancing at a very young age I
grew up in musical theater and was
fortunate enough to have parents that
really supported me in this traveled the
world at a very young age and musicals
and then when I got to high school I
really fell in love with choreography
and I became very passionate about
contemporary dance so I went to college
and I got my BFA and my bachelor of fine
arts and dance and choreography and
since then I had a really hard time
getting a job as a dancer and so that's
kind of how I found drag and over the
last five years drag has been my medium
for staying a dancer and and you know
being a working the answer
[Applause]
well I only have one signature character
her name is Miss estranja she's crazy
she's loud she's sensitive she's
over-the-top but most importantly she's
a dancer yes is missus Trancas sassiness
gonna come out on stage today I think
the judges are definitely gonna get some
of my sass but you know I'm really here
today to prove that drag is not like a
gimmick or a joke it's an actual real
art form so well I want to be sassy I
really want to let the judges in on my
actual personality and who I am beneath
the wig oh I always turn up and turn out
[Applause]
I'm 29 years old
I'm probably one of the oldest
contestants here actually not old baby
established so the reason So You Think
You Can Dance is because it speaks to a
language that I speak which is a
universal language of dance of movement
I believe no matter where I go in the
world no matter what I look like no
matter who I am as long as I'm able to
move my body I can connect with another
human being
so So You Think You Can Dance to me it
really encompasses this it shows that no
matter if you're a ballroom dancer a
hip-hop dancer a street dancer you know
a contemporary dancer we're all speaking
the same language of movement and I
think this idea of being universal of
coming together accepting one another
for our differences is exactly what we
need in 2018 gosh I vote for you yeah I
vote for you all day
I vote for me too okay can I throw in a
vote for me is there a judge that really
means a lot to you or someone that
you're just really dying to win over
well I know that Nigel's gonna be the
toughest judge I know that he prefers
his male dancers to be very masculine to
be very strong to be very powerful
which I'm all of those things I just
happened to come in a female form okay
so I'm a little nervous about how he's
gonna take this whole drag thing but I
think once he sees me do my dance he's
gonna be wowed if you win season 15 if
So You Think You Can Dance
when I win season 14 when you win season
15 is that the most ultimate dream come
true not only is it a dream come true
for me as a dancer but I believe it's a
dream come true for my community the
LGBT can
and the drag community it would really
speak volumes to our art form and I
think it would legitimize the hard work
I've been doing over the last five years
as a drag queen so I think a win for me
is a win for my community and that's why
so you think a dance should crown
ma ma doing it for the people that's
right she's a People's Queen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]